all right San Diego comic-con is over
had a lot of fun in San Diego comic-con
met a lot of fans had a lot of fun with
fans and I was like not a lot of
trailers just talk about holy [ __ ]
Saturday happen now I have some videos
to do I'm not going to talk about all
the trailers that hit at San Diego
comic-con but I do want to take my pick
of the ones I want to talk about last I
have to review the movies that came out
last weekend also I would love to say a
reviewer is never late
no is it early for this one we're gonna
quote another great wizard we have work
to do
the first trailer I'm going to talk
about is the Justice League trailer
because it was the first one that I saw
and I thought it was really sweet yeah I
thought it was sweet I mean Batman vs
Superman was very divisive among fans
but dude they're all coming together to
fight baddies if you ever read comic
books if you ever watched the animations
you're excited at some level right this
trailer Bruce Wayne's ultimately going
around he's trying to recruit everybody
now he tries to recruit Arthur Currie
yeah he tries to recruit that guy it's
not happening that dude kindly tells him
to go [ __ ] himself by throwing him up
against the wall then he goes to Barry
Allen Barry Allen completely stole this
trailer he steals the show which is
great for me because that's two versions
of the flash that I apparently like but
it's also tough for me because I love
the flash TV show and I love him as
Barry Allen in the flash it's definitely
a different vibe like this kid looks
like he has a lot of tech in his room it
looks like they're going for a young
Tony Stark he's quippy he's nerdy he's
probably reclusive because he says he
needs friends so most importantly he's
fast we see that in the best way
possible because Bruce Wayne after days
he's talking this kids like guy sorry
I'm not him I'm not the flash remember
you think I am he just takes his
battering and Chuck's it as his head and
he's just I love the way time slows down
you see his perspective and he just
steps the lightening the Speed Force
isn't just in his body that thing opens
up and instead you see that he is
tapping into a dimension he's tapping
into a living thing just made it feel
really alive however I felt like a
complete douchebag because when this
trailer was over I was like as lightning
is not yellow I felt like a [ __ ] dick
because I liked the trailer actually
really liked this trailer there's the
one thing I had to say I take it back I
shouldn't even tell you that because
this is the Internet I'm saying it's
sweet I'm just saying I just his
lightnings not wait is it blue it is a
tint of oh my god but you do see that
this trailer has a lighter tone than you
thought it would have had coming off of
Batman for Superman the hardest task
this movie has is making a
for about seven years of time that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has had to
bill but it is doable I was thinking
about it right before I popped on this
camera to talk about this trailer we've
seen many movies where an ensemble of
characters have come together or who
have not had movies leading up to their
coming together Suicide Squad perfect
example we haven't seen those characters
have their own movies before but we're
all loving I'm pumped for the Suicide
Squad holy [ __ ] but another one that we
really hit the point is guardians of the
galaxy all the characters and guardians
of the galaxy at this point are
individually liked and loved by fans but
they didn't have any movies building up
to it just happened they came together
in this one movie and I for one enjoy
the [ __ ] out of it that's how I'm gonna
say it don't see it as the Golden Gods
of comic books who didn't get their
movie leading up to it see it as
characters coming together to fight a
big baddie
that's the cool part while yes enjoying
and indulging in the fact that these
characters happen to be characters that
you may have loved as a child
gross is your eyes at this now by
trailer - I want to believe Justice
League's coming together I'm gonna
forget that whole monologue I just said
yeah all in all I'm excited for this
Justice League movie I for one love
Geoff Johns I've read Justice League by
Geoff Johns I brought Geoff Johns in to
be more involved with the Justice League
movie and if they could translate what
he did for that Justice League onto the
big screen I'm today I'm there I want to
hear what you guys think about it so the
Justice League trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and
yes more videos come and keep an eye on
my channel for the next couple days man
few days man that's a said we have work
to do and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you